pour sauver une vie tapez un c'est ce
que ça prête à faire les téléspectateurs
du grand show du donneur cette si cette
émission est bien diffusée sur une
chaîne de télévision des Pays-Bas
vendredi soir une femme en phase
terminale d'un cancer volontaire pour un
organe choisira avec l'aide du public
entre trois malades en attendant lequel
elle guérira Stéphanie déjà salagi
la bande-annonce fait déjà scandale avis
au téléspectateurs vendredi soir ce sont
deux qui aideront une femme de 37 ans
atteinte d'une maladie incurable à des
partager trois candidats à gagner ses
reins à son décès le dernier concept de
téléréalité imaginé par la célèbre
société ondemol serait diffusée par la
chaîne BNM la chaîne se dissensibiliser
à ce problème depuis la mort de son
président fondateur cet homme qui a
attendu en vain une grève de rein avec
un programme de télévision de très
mauvais goûts nous en avons conscience
d'attirer l'attention sur le don
d'organes et sur le fait que la
situation est très mauvaise
des arguments qui n'ont pas convaincu la
société néerlandaise de transplantation
de reins
je voudrais proposer une solution à la
chaîne de télévision vous avez eu toute
la
publicité
en France les médecins se disent
également choqués par ce programme
cette émission ne pourrait pas avoir
lieu en France car dans notre pays on
respecte toujours les grands principes
des lois de bioéthiques qui sont d'abord
l'anonymat entre donneurs et receveurs
et ensuite la gratuité du dos dans une
société hollandaise pourtant très
tolérante le scandale a désormais gagné
la sphère politique les députés de la
majorité se divisent et sans poids sur
l'opportunité d'interdire l'émission au
Pays-Bas comme en France le don d'organe
est en théorie anonyme et gratuit seul
un donneur de reins peut choisir de son
vivant le receveur si un lien entre est
établi